-Ah, I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm so happy I'm here, too.
-I'm so happy.
I'm the biggest fan.
I love that you're here.
Congrats on "SNL."
That's going to be fun.
-Yeah.
-This is your first
U.S. talk show.
-It is.
-Yes.
-I know --
-Thank you for choosing us.
Thank you for choosing me.
I appreciate it.
-What? I'm a huge fan.
I wanted to come,
like, since forever.
I've seen the videos.
-Yeah.
-Your videos.
I thought it was on Instagram
or YouTube.
And I'm always like, "I really
want to talk with him."
-Oh, no, I'm so happy.
And I just want to make sure
I'm saying your name right.
-Okay.
-Rosalía.
-Not bad.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-No, really.
No. Actually not bad.
-Okay.
-Because, usually,
people I see here, they --
you don't really r-r-roll
the R's so much, no?
-Wow.
You just really r-rolled --
-Like -- Yeah. R-R-Rosalía.
-Ooh. R-R-Rosalía.
-[ Laughs ]
-Like that? Like that?
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wasn't bad. That wasn't bad.
I've heard so many options.
Like -- Rosalina.
-Rosalita.
-Rosalita. But --
Yeah, it's usually,
like, Rosalina...
-Rosalina.
-Rowzalia.
-Rowzalia. Rosalía.
-Thank you.
That's it right there. Yes.
Welcome. You are --
You started
as a flamenco singer.
But your music today
is made up of so many genres.
You've kind of destroyed
out there, in the market.
You've won eight Latin Grammys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hello.
Not too shabby. Not bad.
-It happened. It happened.
-Yeah, and then here it is
right here.
"Motomami" is coming out
March 18th.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-I love the drawing.
I love the way it looks.
I love -- Why is it called --
Would I know
what "Motomami" means?
-Mm-hmm.
-I would?
-Okay, so, you want to know
why it's called "Motomami"?
-Yeah.
-'Cause I feel like
Motomami's an energy.
-Oh. I like that.
-[ Laughs ]
Yes, yes. It's like an energy.
-Now, I'm feeling it, yeah.
I'm feeling the Motomami energy.
-That's what I'm saying.
Okay, so --
Maybe -- Probably
you're a Motopapi, too.
-Yeah. Oh, my gosh.
I would totally be -- Yeah.
I'm totally a Motopapi.
-Yeah.
-I am so Moto --
Everyone share that.
That's going to be my nickname.
-How do you know
that you're a Motopapi, though?
-Because I can --
I can just feel it.
Once I --
Once I r-r-rolled the R's,
I knew that I was --
-You're like,
"Yeah, I'm Motopapi."
-I'm Motopapi.
Come on. Yeah.
I can really feel it.
Motomami and Motopapi.
-Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
-You know, I wanted
to ask you this question
because it's --
it has a funny ending.
We were talking backstage.
I was going to say, "Hey,
I heard that you change
your phone number a lot."
You do?
Me -- I used to, too.
-I change it so often.
Before, I used to do it a lot.
-Because too many people
just get your number
and start calling you.
Is that why?
-No, because I didn't
answer the messages.
And then I realized, you know,
that I wanted to focus
beyond the studio and work.
-Ah.
-And now I wanted to focus.
-Yeah, me too.
I wanted to focus, too.
Focus on work.
That's why I changed my number.
Yeah.
-No, I mean it.
And then I was like,
"Okay. Mira. I'd rather not."
Change the phone. Fresh start.
-Yeah.
-You know?
And then what happens is you --
you change your number.
But then people text -- Because
someone else gets that number.
And then your friends
starts texting that number,
not knowing
that you changed yours.
-That happen to you?
'Cause that happened to me.
-Yeah, it does.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean it. That happened to me.
Like, literally, I realized --
'Cause I didn't know
that that happened.
I thought when you use a phone
number, then the phone number --
you know, like, disappears
or something.
I don't know why I thought that.
-Yeah, that should happen.
They should, like, at least wait
a couple of years and then --
-It was your number.
-If it's your number,
at least wait -- Thank you.
If it's your number --
I mean, I'm Motopapi.
I don't mess around.
I go, if you want
to take my number --
If I change it, it should be --
-Period.
-Out. For at least ten years.
-But that doesn't happen.
-No.
-And then I realized
that people --
My friends thought
that they were texting me.
They were texting random people.
-But that happened to you --
For a friend that we know,
as well,
that's been on our show.
Harry Styles.
-Yeah. That happened.
[ Laughs ] That happened.
-So, talk to me.
So, Harry texts you.
-I have proof.
Like, it happened.
-You have proof?
Like, what do you have?
A photo? What do you have?
[ Laughter ]
-I literally have proof.
-Where -- Yeah, no. No problem.
-Okay.
-What are you doing?
Wait. You had your phone
in your boot?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-That's where you keep
your phone?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's so cool.
I'm going to start
doing that, too.
Are you kidding me?
I'm gonna totally keep
my phone in my...
-I'm Motomami.
Even Motomami needs to keep
the phone in the boot.
She keep it in the boot.
-Yes.
-It's perfect
to match the outfit.
It's, like, in the boot.
-Yes.
-You know what I mean?
-It's in the boot, man, yeah.
All right, so you --
-You want to see?
-I really do.
This is a real -- Now,
how did you end up with this?
So, Harry Styles texts you,
thinking it's you.
But it's not. Someone else
has the phone number.
-Yeah.
-And this is real.
-Look, look. Okay, look.
Okay.
-All right. Let me -- All right.
-Can't you believe he thought --
-So, which one is he?
-He sent me.
It's a screenshot, okay.
In the DMs, in Instagram DMs.
-Yeah.
-Saying, "Your texts
are confusing."
-That was Harry that said,
"This is so beautiful"?
-Yeah, he said that.
Because he was like,
"Oh, I love this song."
That is called "Dolerme."
-Yes.
-He sent me --
there's a screenshot --
that he was like --
-"This is beautiful."
And then you wrote back --
or supposedly you wrote back.
-And it wasn't me.
[ Laughter ]
-"I know, my darling."
-The random person said, yeah,
"I know, my darling."
-And then he says, "Love it."
-And then he says...
[ Laughter ]
..."Love you."
-"Love you."
And then Harry says...
"I love you too."
With lots of O's.
Very romantic. Very --
And then this person writes...
-The person says, "Haha sorry.
You're wrong.
I don't know who you are."
[ Laughter ]
-And then --
And then Harry writes back,
"I'm confused."
[ Laughter ]
And then the person puts --
-The person -- Oh, my God.
The person says, "This number
belongs to someone before.
But now it's my number.
So don't bother me anymore.
Good night. Thank you."
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-To Harry --
Dude.
-Imagine -- Imagine --
-To Harry Styles.
-Imagine being that person
now looking
to the "Jimmy Fallon" show
and say,
"I said, 'Don't bother me
anymore,' to Harry Styles!"
[ Laughter ]
-So, Harry just sent it
in your DM and was like,
"Hey, what's going on with you?"
-So he said, "These --
These texts are confusing.
Your texts are confusing."
He says something like that.
And I was like,
"Wait. What do you mean?"
-That's an old number.
Oh, my God.
-And then I realize --
-That is the best thing ever.
-No.
-All right.
Save it.
Protect it in your boot forever.
[ Laughter ]
You know, on TikTok,
you posted how you create
a beat for your song.
And I thought it was very,
very cool and interesting.
I wanted everyone to take
a look at this.
This is Rosalía creating a beat
for her song "Saoko."
-"Saoko."
♪♪
-[ Imitating melody ]
[ Imitating melody ]
♪♪
[ Vocalizing ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Imitating melody ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's so good.
-Jimmy, like the...
-I love that.
Yeah, I love that.
You're doing "Saturday Night
Live" this Saturday.
-Yes.
-Which, of course,
is on Saturday, and it's live.
But you performed on "SNL"
with Bad Bunny,
and you were amazing,
by the way.
-Did you like it?
-I loved it.
He's a pal, and I'm always --
I'm such a fan of yours.
I'm so psyched to meet you
and tell you in person
how much I love you.
-Same.
-I can't wait to watch.
Congrats on everything.
Please come back
with more text messages.
-Yay.
-Yeah. Just text me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Motomami" is out March 18th.
Rosalía, everybody.
Check her out
as the musical guest
this weekend on
"Saturday Night Live."
We'll be right back with
a performance from Omar Apollo.
Stick around.